bonjour Astrid alors quelles sont les
dernières informations dont vous
disposez sur cette attaque de drone
alors plusieurs agences de presse russe
ont cité le ministère de la Défense en
affirmant que c'était un drone ukrainien
qui aurait donc été abattu par les
Russes mais donc les débris auraient tué
trois techniciens sur cette base
militaire ici en Ukraine et bien il y a
eu aucune réaction officielle pour
l'instant début décembre quand Moscou
avait déjà accusé l'Ukraine d'avoir
attaqué plusieurs bases militaires dont
celle d'Engels avec des drones il n'y
avait pas eu d'annonces officielle non
plus donc l'Ukraine ne confirme pas mais
ne nie pas non plus ses attaques mais
ici certains craignent que ce soit
utilisé comme un prétexte pour faire une
nouvelle attaque de la part des Russes
ou bien tout simplement continuer le
conflit
le président zellenski a prévenu ces
dernières heures le peuple ukrainien
qu'il fallait s'attendre à une fin
d'année sombre et difficile il n'y a
donc pas d'accalmie en vue selon lui sur
le terrain en Ukraine
alors non il n'y a pas d'accalmie sur le
terrain et puis de toute façon aucune
trêve de Noël ou du nouvel an un navet
été prévenu le président de qui l'a dit
aujourd'hui c'est aussi kirilo
bouddhanna le chef des renseignements
militaires Ukrainiens qui a réaffirmé
qu'il fallait s'attendre à la même
intensité des combats dans les zones où
ils sont en cours notamment à barmut
dans l'Est mais aussi s'attendre encore
à des alertes aériennes et puis à des
bombardements il y en a eu à Redson
pendant la journée de Noël et puis la
menace continue partout le l'Ukraine a
aussi décidé aujourd'hui de demander
maintenant de l'ONU un symbole
finalement une volonté des Ukrainiens de
montrer que le conflit ne s'arrête pas
et qu'il faut une réaction
internationale plus forte merci pour
toutes ces précisions Astrid Agopian en
direct depuis